foreign
World downpour is a game about
Reinventing an ecosystem about how
precise changes to an environment in the
creatures within it can have an
incredible effect on a simulated
biosphere in the expansion there are
five new slug cats to play as all of
which feature not just new game
redefining abilities but new regions
suited for those abilities and new
creatures to test their limits and liken
the original base game everything runs
on a unique system of procedural
animation and AI that makes this
pixelated ecosystem feel truly alive so
for this entry into the archive we'll
discover the hidden depths of rain World
downpour now let's reshuffle the roles
of this virtual food chain
the First new slug cat is the Gourmand a
rather rotund creature that at a glance
seems stuck at the bottom of the
evolutionary Heap for the Gourmand is
unable to run as fast or climb as far as
most slug cats even something as simple
as throwing a spear will Tire them out
causing them to enter a winded State
until they can catch their breath in the
race to survive the adorable Gourmand
sadly doesn't seem like they'll cross
the finish line but they have an ability
that changes everything if you hold any
two items in each hand this clever
creature will combine them to create
something new find yourself in a dark
room the Gourmand can combine glowing
slime mold with a rock to create a
lantern or combine a gunpowder plant
with a Spore puff to create an explosive
or a beehive with a vulture grub to
create a blinding flashbang the sheer
number of things you can make is
completely nuts as this chart from the
wiki proves and if you you don't have
ingredients the resourceful Gourmand can
simply cough one up at the cost of a
food they're the definition of work
smarter not harder the Gourmand has
other drawbacks like how they need a
more sizable stockpile of food to
hibernate but the more you play the more
you fall into the gourmand's pattern of
life in one of the coolest tricks
downpour pulls you learn to think like
the slug cat you play as to survive the
ecosystem
the gourmand's path eventually takes
them to the new region of the outer
expanse a lush and Lively environment
dotted with ancient ruins it would be
paradise for a creature like the
Gourmand but there are other new
creatures in this Garden caramel lizards
are oversized six-legged brutes that can
perform aggressive leaps to catch their
prey they also have the ability to spit
projectiles that can knock the Gourmand
down or stick them in place motivated by
the promise of a tasty treat caramel
lizards will use every weapon at their
disposal to try and catch the Gourmand
and like the creatures from the base
game these enemies are powered almost
entirely by procedural animation and
emergent Behavior which makes them feel
like living organisms this approach is
insanely cool and was also insanely
difficult to get right according to the
developers whom I interviewed for extra
Insight our project we set out to do was
what if we base its entire entirely
around emergent Behavior we would ask
ourselves like this stuff is so cool
like why don't other games do this and
we found out they're right not to do
this although a challenge to develop the
tech behind creatures like the caramel
lizards make them engaging Rivals to the
Gourmand but while not a master
combatant this slug cat has some very
Gourmand ways to handle threats in a
pinch they can fall from enough height
to stun their enemies with their sheer
bulk even better if you give caramel
lizards enough of the right type of food
you can turn them into your allies for
like the Gourmand their fellow food
lovers
unfortunately some creatures find
nothing quite as tempting as the
Gourmand themselves in the humid
Wetlands of the utter expanse jungle
leeches will try to latch on to the
Gourmand these green leeches are able to
stay out of the water for long periods
without drying up and slowly drain the
food from their hosts get overwhelmed
and the Gourmand becomes dessert
this jungle might not be the easiest
environment for the Gourmand to navigate
but the determined little slug cat will
keep hauling themselves along to make
traversal easier you can get a helping
hand from the yeeks these energetic
frog-like creatures are passive life
forms that jump around incessantly and
if you grab hold of one you can greatly
increase your jumping ability they
especially come in handy in areas dense
with worm grass which will try to pull
the Gourmand in to feed Yik traversal is
another example of the Gourmand using
their intelligence to overcome their
shortcomings
ultimately the gourmand's journey is a
story of learning to work your way up
from the bottom of the food chain and if
you eat every type of food it unlocks an
incredible piece of post-game content
that I'll reveal at the end of the video
but the next slug cat the artificer
isn't interested in the joys of life in
many ways the gourmand's opposite this
aggressive creature is an expert in
explosives able to turn any regular
spear into an explosive one or cough up
a grenade these weapons encourage an
aggressive playstyle that can result in
Blowing yourself up but fortunately the
artificer is immune to explosive damage
in fact blowing themselves up is the
main way they get around as they can
create a small mid-air explosion to give
their jump extra height while tricky to
use at first this explosive jump soon
becomes integral to navigating the
environment it encourages you to
approach movement with the same
aggressive momentum as combat
but like the Gourmand the artificer has
downsides use the explosive jump too
much and you'll start smoking and if you
jump again you'll be knocked unconscious
ignore this warning and it's game over
but while the artificer is a danger to
themselves they are even more dangerous
to their many enemies for this vengeful
slug cat is hunting the most intelligent
creatures in Rain world the Scavengers
in the original game the advanced
scavenger groups could be reasoned with
and would only attack if you cause
trouble but in this game their ai's
aggression is locked at maximum and
they'll use their considerable
intelligence to try and take the
artificer out as you move through the
game they'll send out assassination
squads set up ambushes and even unleash
their Ultimate Weapon Elite scavengers
an eye for an eye response to the
artificer's escalation these Hunters
have unique masks in electrified Spears
that do extra damage they're also
considerably more mobile able to LEAP
long distances and smoke you out if you
try and hide Somewhere Out Of Reach it
can really feel like you're battling in
autonomous intelligence instead of
enemies in a video game
you have these AI creatures that have
their own agency right and they have all
of these various competing impulses I
guess you'd say
the artificer's path of violence
eventually leads them to the metropolis
a crumbling ancient city you can access
thanks to an ID drone that accidentally
links with you you're here to flush out
the Scavengers but even while you're on
the warpath it's hard not to be moved by
the beautiful environments of this
region which tell a haunting story of a
civilization that vanished in some areas
the technology still functions with
rooms that continue to Glow with
holographic displays and even some low
gravity Chambers home to neuron flies
these multi-colored drone swarms seem to
store data and while they might seem
defenseless messing with them is a bad
idea for the neuron flies have a
protector inspectors or bizarre
multi-headed artificial beings
programmed to defend the neurons worm at
all costs if you snatch a fly their
bodies will flash red and they'll go on
the offensive flinging the artificer
around the room or catching Spears
mid-air and since each head seems to
have their own AI their unique challenge
to outwit the only way to defeat this
mechanical Hydra is to destroy all three
heads after which the inspector will
explode it seems wherever the artificer
goes destruction follows
if you continue to blaze onwards you
will eventually come face to face with
the chieftain scavenger a unique being
that won't attack you outright giving
you a final chance to turn back but at
this point you see the world as the
artificer does and violence is likely
your first instinct if you do decide to
battle the chieftain you're in for a
fight more challenging than any other
scavenger you faced no matter the
outcome however the artificers seem
stuck in an endless cycle of Destruction
in the game does a great job pulling you
into that cycle of escalation
encouraging you to tear through the
ecosystem with explosive recklessness
yet the middle slug cat the rivulet
survives not by strength but agility the
rivulet can run faster climb faster and
swim faster than a typical slug cat in
fact the rivulet is so quick they can
outmaneuver creatures like the Leviathan
which in the base game were virtually
impossible to escape from on your own
and thanks to the rivulet's Primitive
gills they can also stay underwater for
long periods these adaptations are
absolutely critical to the rivulet
survival as at this point in the
timeline the rain comes so frequently
that the land has become a drowned
Kingdom of unending floods in the
rivulates Attunement to their
environment was quite intentional they
were kind of this look at that sparked
off the idea of what if all these new
cell cats had some region or ecosystem
that ties into their abilities
yet the rivulet is not the only life
form that is adapted to this new
environment eels are aquatic Hunters
that slither in the bowels of this
waterlogged dominion and seem to be an
offshoot of the lizards they propelled
their slender bodies through the water
with their long spiny tails the
bioluminescent glow of their heads
casting in Eerie light in open Waters
packs of eels will cut the rivulet off
from all angles their AI Works a bit
like the salamanders of the base game if
they had their reaction time and
Mobility dialed all the way up
but there are larger and more aggressive
Predators than eels in these waters
aquapedes are another major threat to
the rivulet huge aquatic centipedes with
a bottomless appetite seemingly a
relative of flying Center wings that
have turned their wings to Flippers
aquapedes might make you think twice
about taking a swim
yet the more you play as the rivulet the
more navigating The Depths becomes
second nature eventually you gather the
courage to dive deep into the submerged
superstructure a late game region that
is almost entirely underwater and in
these recesses the deadliest aquatic
predator skulks in the form of the giant
jellyfish occasionally spotted closer to
the surface these gargantuan
siphonophores can sense their prey
through vibrations in the water move too
much and the giant jellyfish will send
out their tentacles in pursuit of the
rivulet dragging them in close and
administering a lethal electric shock
from an orb-shaped organ yet these
tentacles have a maximum range and if
you're well practiced you can lure the
tentacles out and then swim right under
them
by the end of the rivulet storyline you
truly feel like an Olympic swimmer and
are more at home in the water than on
the land despite the abundance of
predators
but what about a slug cat that doesn't
avoid Predators but is one the
spearmaster isn't at first unassuming
creature that pulls spear-like quills
from its tail when thrown these Spears
can impale and drain the life from other
organisms and since the spearmaster is
unable to eat due to having no mouth
leeching off other species is the only
way to stay alive this seemingly simple
change turns the entire game of rain
World on its head because now instead of
being constantly on the run from
carnivores you or the carnivore seeking
out other life forms and slowly draining
them like a tiny vampire
yet the spearmaster is not Invincible it
exists in an era long before the other
slug cats where competition is fierce
and predators are more numerous and some
predators are so dangerous even a
biological Terror like the spearmaster
needs to be careful mother spiders or
huge arachnids that Scuttle in the dim
corners of the region their abdomen
swollen due to carrying their brood
attack 1 in a horde of ravenous
coalescipedes are Unleashed infant
spiders that link together into a
centipede-like formation to attack the
player this protective swarm can
overwhelm the spearmaster in seconds
which is why it is fortunate that mother
spiders will avoid confrontations if you
keep your distance
but not all predators offer this
courtesy stowaways or near invisible
Ambush predators that impale their prey
with long fleshy tendrils then pull them
upwards towards their perch on the
ceiling where a mouth rimmed with Jagged
fangs swallows them whole battling
stowaways is exceedingly risky as one
often doesn't spot them until it's too
late and it's not just the slug cat the
stowaway can catch off guard as they'll
eat anything they can drag up into their
gullet it can be hard not to feel
outclassed as a predator when dealing
with such an effective Hunter
and there is no Hunter more effective
than the mother longlegs a primordial
ancestor of the other long-legged
species this artificial terror is a
tentacled mass that prowls the garbage
wastes feeding on anything that gets
stuck in its web of tendrils although
unable to see the mother longlegs reacts
dynamically to sound able to lock onto
prey if they make the slightest whisper
yet while these Terrors are virtually
Invincible if you're careful you can
actually impale the mother long legs and
leech off their energy proving it's not
the size of the hunter that matters but
the tenacity
and the more you settle into playing as
the spearmaster the Bolder you become
working your way up the food chain until
everything feels like it's on the menu
if the final slug cat is the
spearmaster's spiritual opposite the
saint is perhaps the most unique slug
cat of all because they are pacifists if
you try to throw a spear the saint will
toss it so that it spins uselessly
through the air try to eat another
animal even something as small as a bug
and the saint will become sick crawling
around in a day's State its plants and
fungi only for this slug cat in the
brutal ecosystem of rain world the saint
seems hopelessly exposed but they have a
very unusual trick up their sleeve using
a long chameleon-like tongue as a
grappling hook they can lift themselves
Out Of Reach of hungry mouths this
tongue greatly increases their Mobility
allowing them to swing themselves
through the ruined environment they call
home for the saint lives at the absolute
tail end of rain world's timeline in an
era where the land seems locked in a
brutal Ice Age the rain has been
replaced with unforgiving snowstorms
cloak talking the desolate remains of
the ecosystem in a funeral shroud of
white stared in the cold too long and
you will slowly freeze with the saint
becoming paler and paler as their
metabolism shuts down the only way to
endure this forsaken climate is to take
frequent shelter
but this ecosystem is not completely
Barren the pale strawberry lizards
trudged through the snowstorm managing
to cling to life and like all lizards
from past eras these Ice Age reptiles
are predators to catch the saint
strawberry lizards have convergently
evolved to the same grapple tongue
methods of locomotion making them one of
the most maneuverable and unpredictable
predator species of any era using their
tongue the lizards will fling themselves
at the Saint grappling onto the ceiling
next to them or even the saint
themselves trying to anticipate how the
lizard's AI will interact with the
game's physics system is exceedingly
difficult
yet even in competition it is hard not
to feel strangely sorry for these
lizards who like you are doing all they
can to survive in this endless winter
these are creatures of the snow focused
primarily on outlasting the cold
not all creatures are interested in
playing it cool in the warm hued region
of the Rubicon an underground Locale
exclusive to the Saints storyline the
hot tempered fire bugs quickly go on the
offensive if you accidentally start a
one they will quite literally explode
with anger sending their eggs scattering
and careening towards the saint like a
heat-seeking missile not one to forget a
grudge they will continue to pursue you
until they find their target it's best
to behave like a saint and give them no
reason to get aggressive
yet the final life form is as needlessly
aggressive as the saint is peaceful
swooping in on massive Wings miros
vultures or a whirlwind of teeth and
Claws that give a whole new meaning to
death from above the miro's vulture is
Relentless in its path of Destruction
moving through areas like a living
natural disaster if their beak they can
slay you in one hit and the blades on
their wings Aren't Enough the mirrors
vultures glowing eye can also unleash a
laser that explodes with concussive
force but even this nightmare of a
predator is often no match for the
Saints simple passive avoidance you can
defeat miros vultures the same way you
defeat the snow by staying calm and
waiting out the storm like all the slug
cats before it playing as the saint will
make you think like one approaching all
situations with a clear mind and
avoiding fights instead of starting them
each of the five campaigns change both
the ecosystem and the way you think
about your place in it and if you
fulfill all the requirements in the
gourmands campaign you unlock something
very special the next time you boot up
the game you might encounter a bonus
creature the slug pups these adorable
infant slug cats offer a new way to
navigate the game because now you can be
a parent and you can take them by the
hand or carry them all the way to the
end and you can adopt more than one make
sure you're ready for the extra
responsibility though because once a pup
bonds with you it becomes your duty to
protect them from the dangers of rain
World which can be extremely stressful
but it's a cool hidden system with a
surprising amount of depth we basically
have one person on the team that let's
just solely devoted to developing the
slip Clips it's a very big project it's
huge
no matter how you get to the end each of
the new slug cats has at least one
conclusion that wraps up their journey
in a poignant yet unexpected way if
you'd like to check out the expansion
for yourself once again be aware that
the game is exceedingly difficult I've
never felt more aware of my vulnerable
place in a virtual ecosystem than when
playing rain World which is by Design
Ringworld is about humility right it's
like you're you're not some big hero
you're just this little creature a
tremendous thank you to the creative
minds behind this game for sharing
insights into how the ecosystem came
together it's been an honor exploring
this pixelated biosphere
as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video